[Music]
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum i was trying to
uh
feel uh or act
a little more excited a little more uh
pep in my step but uh yeah this last uh
this last week this you know things
things catch up to you and uh you know
it's it's hard because you don't like
i'm not gonna feel sorry for myself i'm
not gonna
you know how dare i there's all these
people
suffering and uh protesting all this
stuff and i you know it's
it's just horrible so you don't feel
like you have the right to feel anything
except
uh i don't know me anyway i feel guilty
like
why should i feel why should i feel
anxious why should i feel depressed well
because it's the world
we're living in that's why and it's
everywhere
so in other news uh we had a great guest
today
um also uh check out the instagram
uh handles at inside of you podcast and
twitter
at inside of your pod i'm on facebook uh
my patreon is awesome it's just a huge
community
we uh it's inside of you on patreon
patreon and my patrons are amazing and
it's such a
it's so much fun just take a look at it
i think you'll dig it and i have another
patreon that's just with john heater
about horror movies called where have
all the good horror movies gone
check that out if you want that's about
it really camp rosie is uh
still planned for october 31st week and
halloween weekend
adult summer camp that i created and my
friend old davey
in new york is helping me out with it so
hopefully we'll be uh smooth sailing by
then who knows i don't i don't know
i just can't i can't not plan for things
i'm not going to just cancel things
because it sucks now
and i will say this i don't get
political
i said one tweet on the um on the
twitter
and it just said if you are not upset
by uh what happened to george floyd
you're not a human being and i that's
that's the one tweet i sent
i stand by it i can't imagine anyone
watching that and thinking otherwise
um i don't get political but this is
uh it's heartbreaking
and every time i've seen it i won't
watch it anymore it's just it feels like
the first time i
can't believe i'm watching that
something like that would happen and the
guy with a pot
his hand in his pocket it just
man it just enrages me
so callous sitting there like hey
the man is i'm not gonna get him you've
heard it a million times so let's get
away from that let's get into something
else let's get into
henry winkler buffons uh barry
you'd love this guy he's been in a lot
of sandler films scream
the guy is just i love this man
and um he's sort of like a father figure
to me always checks in on me
and uh we're gonna check in on him so
let's get inside of henry winkler it's
my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you
with michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
is there an introduction no we're just
starting
yeah yeah i do an introduction later oh
you do
i obviously we worked together a long
time ago you were on here a while ago
when the
podcast first started and i remember
being in a
plane with you and i remember
then you were always clean i'd call it
maybe a little ocd in a way i'm ocd with
certain things
oh no no i i i carried
for my entire um uh
at least the last 10 years i washed down
the entire area in the pocket
the magazine i watched it people next to
me
i watched the people next to me my arm
yeah your arm
uh because i always thought you know
the wonderful people who clean a plane
are under such pressure
to clean it so fast in order to get the
next passengers on
i wasn't sure the airline
cared about the cleanliness i needed
well you know that made me think of
today
and the situation we're all in and it
made me think wow if henry was cleaning
[ __ ] up then
boy is he looking out now i i don't
imagine you to be a person who has left
the house
probably in quite some time no i leave
the house i need to walk
so let me ask you with all this i look
at you
and you look well you look comfortable
you've got the beer going
are you growing the hair out in the
beard it's is it for barry
when it ever comes back no i you know
what we were one
day away from filming
we were at the table reading the scripts
all together as a cat so you knew the
lines probably for the first episode
and we were sent home and i've never
left you know i go to the grocery store
now i've stopped doing that my old
my my children have begged me not to go
well you're healthy but still but max
and zoe go what do they tell you to go
to instacart
and right you know can i get you
something
uh they will go instead but i love just
going out
you know with my mask and my gloves
and i take a uh i take
my uh my clorox
oh yes so when i take something off the
shelf i wipe it down
before i put it in my car i love that
i mean you're someone who is so busy
your entire life
you you look at your resume you look at
henry is always doing something
he's directing he's producing he's
writing he's at a con he's at
you you're lecturing you're being a dad
you're being um
so you're always doing something and all
of a sudden now a lot of people look at
this
i'm not saying so many people have it
way worse this is not a
we're not talking about that i'm just
saying i'm just saying how it affects
people's lives and how
your life has been affected well it it
slowed us down
we started doing jigsaw puzzles um
[Music]
you know if it goes on much longer i
will have to think because
you know as a uh uh the the family
there are 13 members now and
people need help there are
good acquaintances of the family who
need help
so you do what you can do you think
there is the
the world that needs help and you do
what you can
well what about therapy do you feel like
you know i could
probably use this do you go to therapy
i i have gone to therapy yeah recently
yeah recently sure i love therapy
i have learned
the more you know about yourself the
more you know about
every human being on this on this earth
and what have you found out about
yourself that you didn't know
i was uh
not necessarily um
as strong as i thought i was i was not
um i was not as together
as i thought i was and then through
therapy you learn you know what i think
you know
this is exactly why i see it i see
myself as a
big block of swiss cheese
and through therapy i'm trying to become
cheddar
i'm trying to fill in all the holes
are there some things that you when you
find out about yourself
is it sort of are you taken aback by
like wow
is that me am i not do you aspire
to prove and almost prove your therapist
wrong
but when you hear something they say
you're like i want to be more of that
how do i get there and do you see
yourself doing the work
i i say when i find something i go
not that i'm you know what it does i
it makes me sad that it took me this
long
to figure that out whatever that
is uh i wasted so much time
in my life um
you know not looking for the ants or not
uh looking for a way to
uh blossom like a flower like a flower
like a rose you know i i wish i had done
it
uh in my 20s but what is that one thing
is it a a culmination of things uh
i'm more defensive than i thought it was
you're a defensive person
i can be and i i thought i wasn't
and who did is it something you hear
from other people
for a while and then you realize oh wait
they're right and you kind of
i don't believe you i'm not defensive
i'm and then someone objectively tells
you you know
i finally when you talk about it i
finally
see the behavior happening going oh
this is it you know when when you are
first
told about something whether it be from
a friend or uh
your your spouse or your children or
your therapist or whatever it is
it sounds like they're speaking russian
when they're trying to tell you about
yourself
and you're not open to see it it's like
a foreign language
and one day
all of a sudden it makes sense you go
oh that's what they meant because you're
actually
seeing it in in action
and what do you get from that yeah what
do you get from that when you uh
honestly when you
realize what you're doing you do exactly
you can catch yourself
i got i get i go i'll tell you what i
get i get
oh i
i love emerging
from the the cocoon
yeah i'm coming out and i'm
feeling good do you
still feel bigger more expensive
do you i could see it happening now it
just makes you happy that you've
acknowledged
that do you do you find yourself why
you're doing this
uh while you're talking to someone and
you you could feel yourself defensive
and do you ever stop yourself and saying
do you acknowledge it i'm being
defensive or are you just correct
no i don't you you know what i
you know i used to do this with my kids
they would come in and i would
be angry about uh something you know a
rule broken or whatever
and all of a sudden i would hear my
parents
fly out of my mouth and i would go wait
all right hold it that's not what i
meant to say
that's not the way i meant to say it i'm
backing up
this is what i meant to say
and you know what when you admit that
your children don't think you're
weak or you're less than they go oh wow
thanks you're well you you acknowledge
me and this
is at six or 26.
go on yeah oh yeah
or they would come in and i would be in
touch and i would go what
i just want to say it's
it's right here whatever is bothering me
is right here
and it's going to come right out so you
have a choice
you can either continue or
leave the room and come back um
and let's talk later and eventually the
children would come in
size me up i'll see you later
it was just no wow you know what dad
i'm gonna take a break yeah well i'm
gonna give you a break
i'm not gonna talk to you about this
right now i'm gonna come back
oh my god i don't i just don't think
that was in my parents vocabulary i
don't think you know
what do you know what it is something
that you
do with other people and then you make
it
something you do it can be an adult it
can be a child it can be anybody
when you're in touch to say you know
what now is not a good time
and i'm telling you you do that twice
another human being if they are at
all aware they're going to see
oh yeah you know what i'll come back
i'm going to have a a bagel and some
cream cheese
there's something really powerful about
that and i'll tell you what else is
powerful
it's powerful when you could when you're
sitting there and you're having a
conversation
and you start to realize why am i
pushing this why why am i pushing this
person
and still sort of even though you're
like i'm right i'm right why am i doing
this though what do i have to
why am i why do i have to be right and
there's something in stopping yourself
and saying you know what
i'm sorry i this is just to stop and say
hey
this is ridiculous i'm i'm i'm worked up
about this and i don't need to be right
and you don't need
i don't know i've done that and when i
do that i feel better to just stop and
say
apologize to someone because you know
what you're exactly right michael
and i and i'll tell you that to just
make that your habit
oh i just realized i'm reflected in the
steve martin poster
behind you i'm on the screen twice
you are yeah for you but not for me
if you turned around you would see that
i'm in the poster
right um by the red uh bottom you know
steve martin you know steve martin
i met him twice
i went to see his show at the troubadour
right
i uh met him on the plane
going to las vegas to celebrate a
birthday he was on the plane
he i did him a favor
four times i did him a favor when he
appeared
at universal amphitheater
and i just walked on stage when he was
singing
king tut king tut moved from
behind him and because i did him that
favor
when i produced ron howard's celebration
for cinema tech he got the cinema tech
award
i don't know if they even do that
anymore uh i
ron howard i mean uh uh steve martin
came and was part of that celebration so
you consider him a friend
no an acquaintance an acquaintance it's
hard to
it's hard to differentiate that in
hollywood isn't it i mean you meet
someone
you see them you get along you know
everybody's friends everybody's you know
oh yeah i'm friends with that guy i'm
friends with that guy acquaintance is
kind of like you know i met him
i no longer think i no longer think i
saw
and i can't mention names but i'm
walking on the beach
in malibu and i saw
two titans at that time
in the industry one was the head of an
uh a massive agency one was the head
of a studio and they
were best friends
but their friendship was as best
as their need was and as soon as the
need was over
and the industry changed
so when when people don't need each
other in a certain way i need you for
this industry anyway
isn't that something yeah now there are
certain people
that are really good friends you and i
have stayed in touch we have stayed
close
uh we did a pilot many years ago that
didn't go anywhere
um and there has never been
a need for us to be friends except for
we really like each other yeah i do i
admire you i feel like you're
a mentor not only to me but for you know
a lot of people
and uh i i just like you you know i i
think of uh
i always tell you this but my one regret
is not going fly fishing with you
and i will someday show up somewhere
where you're fly fishing
it's a magnificent thing to do fly
fishing but
a general friendship in this industry
is based on need the need of each other
uh in the industry not because we
respect each other
that makes me sad and i and i know
you're right
it's a reality and it also makes you
sort of
be a little guarded with people doesn't
it it makes you feel like you know i
know what they want from me and they're
nice to me now when they need me
that's another thing i learned you don't
have to be guarded
i have learned to let people
in at varying degrees
i enjoy people very much i enjoy meeting
people and then
um but i don't have to let them all the
way in
in order to be then disappointed and
have to flush them out
what about bill hader oh billy
will he be a friend for life i
hope so i have great talks with bill
i do great work with bill he
guides me he writes for me
i mean i'm i'm only talking about myself
now not just the rest
but we have had wonderfully
oh my wife is called get it get it yeah
hi honey i'm at the computer
i'm doing a zoom interview with
michael rosenbaum tyler
so i'll call you later uh
bill hater so you say you hope because
it's a relationship you have it's not
like you go dancing with him you don't
go with eating with the man
sometimes you have lunch but you know
this is a work relationship you like him
you enjoy him
how do you not he seems like such a
wonderful guy he's so
complex he's such a
great creator
and goofy
um seem like a wonderful dad
he i i'm crazy about him
that's awesome i i you know only time
will tell
you know how many leading men can you
say that about that you've worked with
where you're not
you know you're obviously both so
important to the show you're both
emmy award winners and but like how many
guys have you worked with co-stars that
you actually
really like um well adam sandler
ron howard definitely
um um
the other the other guys from happy days
marion ross
oh yeah oh my god oh my god
oh jason bateman
i always write jason bateman about uh
what he has done either i've seen him in
a movie or
uh you know his uh ozark
i mean there are others there are others
there are some people that i
i called after we worked together in the
80s
right and i'm still waiting for them to
return
and we're in 2020 son of a [ __ ]
and i i'm an internal optimist do you
get offended when uh
someone doesn't reciprocate when someone
if you send it if someone doesn't send a
message you
back to you you get a little offended
you it hurts you it used to it took me a
while
to i send a message i've done what i
wanted to do
that's it do you ever send another one
just in case that went to junk
no because a lot of times they are hand
written letters
that's special i don't think a lot of
people write uh have handwritten letters
yeah sometimes i feel
so compelled to write
a letter uh sam rockwell uh he did a
with michelle williams i wrote them both
um
[Music]
sandy newton uh there is an english show
called line of duty
line of duty uh it's on uh i shouldn't
say this because i
i'm an hbo guy but it's on an
another network i think that's okay huh
you could do that
it's okay you like other shows that are
on the other networks that's normal i
wrote
sandy newton in season four was
wow extraordinary that was almost the
christopher walken you did just there
wow christopher walken i did i worked
with him in click
what a guy oh you know what i was a
freshman at yale drama school
i and as a freshman you couldn't act
so i was an usher
and uh christopher walken started
as a dancer on broadway he was a dancer
and he was that he turned actor and he
was
um uh hired by the professional
uh repertory company at yale to play in
caligula
wow and i watched him every night
he was amazing and then years later i
was in click with him
and what'd you say to him you came up to
him and said it chris yeah
i was there i was a student when you
were a professional
in the company well i i remember that i
did call it
time he remembered because he's a very
idiosyncratic fellow
then i saw him on broadway and i i
with um zoe kazan and
and sam rockwell in
[Music]
i left my hand or i left my left hand in
seattle
that's probably not the title
but he was they were amazing that's
awesome yeah i worked with walken too
and i just remember
you know me at the very end of the shoot
i wait till the last day and i said
hey could you sign my um it was king of
new york dvd
it was like 90 something he goes sure
and i go yeah i just put to michael uh
from chris whatever so he goes
to michael from chris
walken and then he wrote
2020 circle then goes oh no 2001
whatever it was he goes no it's 2 000
not that it matters but it was it was 2
000 he circled
2 000 in my face
i'll tell you he was he's a weird guy
wow
but so good so talented
inside of you is brought to you by fair
harbor i'm wearing fair harbor every day
may i drop dead i'm not lying to you
every day i wear fair harbor
fair harbor has reinvented the swimsuit
by replacing
all mesh lining with their super soft
built-in boxer brief liner i'm telling
you you could wear these all day you
could exercise you could swim you could
do whatever
you're not gonna chafe how many
swimsuits you go and they're just
uncomfortable and you're just scratching
yourself and people like what the
what's wrong with that guy all their
products this is unbelievable
they're made from recycled plastic
bottles fair harbor has recycled over
2.5 million plastic bottles
keeping plastic out of waterways and off
of beaches fair harbor makes products
for you to enjoy the places you love and
protects those places at the same time
and guess what you're going to try them
in fact i gave uh my
all my friends i emailed them and uh
they gave uh yeah
so my friends are all ordering them now
i really love this stuff and i love that
brother and sister created this company
they just always hung out the beach
they said how do we protect the
environment and on top of it they made
the best product
as the best pair of shorts i've ever
worn and they make a bunch of other
stuff too
twenty percent off for everyone
listening right now
head to fairharberclothing.com use the
code inside
20 20 off that's inside
20 and say goodbye
to mesh lining forever inside of you is
brought to you by sun basket
boy do i need sun basket there's no
doubt about that i'm tired of ordering
delivery during this whole thing and and
just
even before that it's like there's
nothing like getting a healthy meal
just at your door exactly what you want
and you could put it together in like 15
minutes i can put it together in 15
minutes like a healthy good meal
if you're looking to reduce unnecessary
trips out trying to avoid
sold out grocery stores check out some
basket it's a perfect
and delicious solution for the times
we're living in
sun basket delivers healthy delicious
meals straight to your door
delicious recipes for all kinds of
dietary preferences and this is what i
love
because yeah i am gluten free and i
dairy makes me fart a little bit
so i can get whatever i want mediterra
mediterranean vegetarian paleo
gluten-free
with everything pre-portioned and ready
to prep and cook you can enjoy a full
dinner
of organic produce and clean ingredients
in as little as 15 minutes no matter how
much experience you have in the kitchen
each week
sun basket offers a wide range of
recipes to choose from
so you can try mouth-watering dishes
such as look i love the roasted salmon
with miso glazed eggplant
i just do i think it's absolutely
just feels right in my body
black bean tostados diablo with cabbage
slaw and guacamole
hoist and steak strip lettuce cups with
pickled
decon and carrots i gotta try that one i
haven't tried the steak strip
sun basket facilities have the highest
levels of food and employee safety
reinforcing strict adherence to their
existing standard operating procedures
and increasing sanitization
frequency in their distribution centers
in order to protect
you and your family that's nice to know
when they deliver that stuff that that's
what they're thinking because how many
times ago i'm getting a delivery
i guess i should just like really
wonder what's in there right now
sunbasket is offering 35
off your order when you go right now to
sunbasket.com
iou and enter the promo code iou at
checkout
35 off your order sunbasket.com
iou and enter promo code
i o u you know i was reading all this
stuff
on online about you just uh you know on
on twitter how
you know you always i like how you just
sort of talk about what's happening with
you and one thing kind of
just you know you say i know you're
dyslexic you know
you've written books about these things
about a character your character
character
uh hey can i show you can i be
it's my newest book with lynn oliver
what
it's um from it's a middle school reader
and it's called alien superstar we just
turned in
the second volume the the second
installment
and it's about this alien who leaves his
planet
and the the rocket ship lands the only
address they know in america
which is the back lot of universal
studios
and uh he gets a job on a sitcom
as an alien and what is the sort of the
message in there
well the underlying message is a comedy
how we write only comedies right
but the underlying message is body
shaming
because the star of the show the the the
mother who manages the the female star
of the show that our
alien gets on is always worried about
calories
always worried about her and you know
lets her have the
the salad but not the egg can't have the
egg in the salad
it's about what happens if i
um acknowledge and and say what my true
self is
will i still be accepted because he can
transform
into an earthling his real name is buddy
burger on the earth
buddy because the first person he meets
on the earth
keeps calling him buddy hey buddy where
you from
hey buddy what's your name buddy and
burger is because he sees a stand
just over the guy's shoulder that says
cheeseburgers 4.95
so he goes buddy burger that's how he
gets his name
see it's and this is for middle
middle kids um a fourth to seventh grade
how important is that how important is
it for them to have that message those
messages
of something of respect friendship
keeping your word
and we don't hit anybody on the head
it's just
woven into the you know it's like uh
hank zipster
yep uh there were so many lessons in
that how many
uh did you do how many books of hank
zips there have been 35 novels for
children and you just ended that
probably a couple years ago right uh two
years ago two years ago was the last
28 28 novels all told in the hang tips
is this a lot of work writing this book
you know what it is a lot of work and
it's hard for me
i mean that is the partnership is
amazing
there are so many different kinds of
partnerships because lynn
does the heavy lifting i do the walking
the talking
she does the sitting at the computer the
typing
she knows the rules of writing
and then she's got an idea and i sit
back and then she does the typing and
then reads it back to me and we argue
over every word
so we're completely intertwined right in
the process
but if i didn't have her there would be
no book
uh you you said because we got into this
because i said dyslexic you said i'm
dyslexic
and when i'm driving to location to set
i have to call the first assistant
director 12 times to guide me
otherwise i would never be on camera gps
guides me to nowhere
yeah that's true i have it on my phone
i've got waze
i've got the gps i type in the exact
address
i then all of a sudden i'm i'm
daydreaming and i didn't hear
where the hell the left was so i have to
call whoever the id
is and say okay this is where i
am how do i get to you and i
always leave early to leave room
for getting lost i have driven by
with my wife our house after dinner
uh when we used to be able to go out i
drove
she said were you gonna turn into the
driveway
or are you surprising me
does this happen a lot does it worry
your wife like i need you to go see a
doctor i need you to
have your mind looked at or to she this
has always been part of henry
she knows my problem has this always
been though
besides the dyslexia always
i can't find my keys and help me
technically i could never zoom
you have to invite me i can i don't know
how to invite somebody
right but this so this has nothing to do
i mean you're obviously a really smart
guy
i can't figure out things that others
you know i have
you know difficult i've always liked
with reading and things like that and
comprehending i have to usually read it
a couple of times i have to to absorb it
my add
it just is too overwhelming where i have
to really
focus and it's hard so learning lines
do you have problems with that
absolutely i work on it
and i know i've got a problem you know
what it is it's also accepting this is
who i am
so this is what i have to do if i want
to pursue what i love
yeah do you i thought i couldn't fly
fish because i don't have great eye
hand coordination played ball
um softball for the first time when i
was 28 years old
uh for the team of the happy days team
uh they taught me in between scenes on
the set
stage 19 paramount studios uh
walter von uni was our dialogue coach
supervisor and
ron and anson and donnie taught me
how to play ball um in
behind the cameras were you good did you
turn up being a good player
i was a great pitcher
and couldn't catch an all-right
hitter and i could run fast
but i became like a shutout pitcher
isn't it something that you probably
focus so much on what you were really
good at that that's why you got great
because you were like
if i can't be good at these other things
this is what i'm going to be great at
yeah but i never
i never thought i could be good like
fishing i never
i i wasted so much time
not fishing because i thought i couldn't
fish
instead of just
try see that's
i think that's the message that i'm
gonna write a book for middle uh
middle graders middle school kids about
just trying
i think that's a very very important
thing you say for years and years i'm
like well i don't sing well i'm not a
great singer i could kind of sing
uh you know so i shouldn't make an album
and then i said [ __ ] it i'm gonna make
an album
and i made an album and it came out last
year and i love it and i you know this
is
and i'm starting to really it's and it's
hard to believe
but when you start doing things just
because you love them and you want to do
them
and you don't think about i'll fail i'm
i have nothing to say except you're
correct
right and you're probably a great
fisherman i
my style is ugly
but i catch the fish all right this is
called
[ __ ] talking with rosenbaum it's for my
patrons they're very
devoted fans answer these quickly molly
w
with the sometimes cynical and
self-centered world we live in how do
you fight through the negativity to be
such a positive and loving
light some of it is natural
some of it is just the way i think
others is
um another if i let that cynicism
in i feel horrible
do i want to feel that way no
i broom it out emily asks what has been
your favorite project to work with adam
sandler
i never have a favorite because it's
always the next one like i don't have a
favorite book
because i always think the next one oh
this this is it this is definitely it
until the next one at which time i go oh
no no no no
it's this one jennifer n favorites
jennifer and do you still keep in touch
with some of the cast from happy days
i do all of them that are still with us
i do nico p you've accomplished so much
in your career what keeps you still
motivated motivated
i don't know i love what i do
you know um uh acting
is like a puzzle where you have to
create a human being except
all the pieces are variations of blue
and i have to put it together and
it makes me so happy
lucas m love your character on uh on
barry does your inspiration for your
character gene come from a real-life
acting coach that you had in the past
there was an acting coach here in la
that i never had
that people uh uh told me
that they wrote
i've had teachers i've had uh from
college and graduate school
in theater i had 14 teachers on which to
draw on my imagination
i have taught four master classes
in my life i talked three at emerson and
one
at no five one at south by southwest and
one at northwestern
and i drew on that wow
and then he came out this year i don't
know what's going to happen
because uh now i know
and i don't know how they're going to
take where they're going to take the
story do you have any say in that
no jamie h who's your favorite actor
and why that could be of all time
it could be anybody now then um anthony
hopkins
spencer tracy uh ron howard
because he was like an unbelievable
acting partner
oh my god um bill i would have to say
bill you know the the kids in my class
on barry each one of them
is a home run hitter unto themselves
and they have so little to do and yet we
are so tight
um ryan um
handsome younger
gosling gosling thank you
okay i couldn't hey tim h was your
favorite uh
what was your favorite guy to hang what
what's that i love him
tim h oh you don't know him but he's
handsome who's your favorite guy to hang
out with on better late than never show
each one is unto themselves
uh bill hater uh bill hater bill shatner
you love bill bill shatner has has read
every book ever written by a human being
on the planet and wants you to know
what's on every page
uh uh terry bradshaw
is as big as oklahoma
uh this is my imitation
of george foreman where anywhere
at any time day or night he sits down
out like a light no he can
nap through chaos that's a gift henry
i wish i could just sleep like that that
is a gift
andrew c jeff dye is adorable
i love jeff dye yeah jeff dye just got a
new puppy
he calls a bud i think he's called bud
and the dog is gorgeous i'm
watching the dog grow up on twitter i
love that little duck he's such a good
guy i just did his podcast
andrew c what's been your favorite
television series to direct
to direct for to date and why oh
i would have to say not a television
series but a movie called memories of
me starring billy crystal and
alan king memories of me
i i'm that and it just touches me
carly t what three books would you
recommend to all children who have a
chance to read
all children there is
i oh i don't know the name of it but it
is
it has no words it is by a
french artist and it
is color and
there's yellow and you press
on the yellow and you turn the page
and you've pushed yellow and blue
together in this lane
amazing that's pretty damn cool yeah
there is um well for children who have a
hard time reading
i would have to say um hank zip sir
because i'll show you why please
these are first second and third grade
readers
uh here's hank and
you'll notice that the font
is different from all other fonts
because it makes it easier
for the beginning reader
to negotiate their eyes and the page
i wish i had this growing up me too
here's hank i'm not kidding i i'm not
because i'm associated with it
it's incredible
and um they're funny i love how proud
you are but you should be proud of that
book can i ask you one more question
one more you're winning an emmy
winning an emmy i mean was it unexpected
were you really truly unexp
not feeling that you weren't gonna win i
have been nominated
about a million times before
you sit there the first emmy i was ever
nominated
somebody gave me a a silver
or keychain that was a thumb
uh you you rubbed your thumb on it was a
worry
uh keychain and i was supposed to take
it with me
and i have been nominated my name has
been
called i never left my chair
and from 1978
until 2018
my name has been called and i left my
chair
and it was exhilarating
were you excited were you were you
nervous
i was nervous i was excited i'm proud
i um i love
that once in my life
i have won the prize
of our industry i'm sorry you know some
people say
i don't care you know what does it mean
it's an award
yeah you know some people say i use it
as a doorstop in the bathroom
i actually don't and it's i think that's
[ __ ] when they say it's on the
dining room table
and uh [ __ ] it [ __ ] it well listen this
has been
great listen i love i love the beard
it's just different it's like i could
see you as jack nicholson day 14 of the
shining
zoe i want you to pick me up some
goddamn frozen peas and max
get your ass over here and i want you to
do something with the dog because it's
bothering me
you look like nicholson kind of michael
that's great
oh thanks now he i met three or four
times
and i he is a one of my favorite actors
he is uh he's like touched by god was he
nice in person
yes like you liked him yes what he said
he was like how are you henry
he nice in syllables you know i met uh
he spoke in syllables well
when i was i was thrilled to meet him in
person
how many times have you seen the shining
uh once
did you love it i'm not great at horror
you don't like scary all right well
all right well listen i love you i'm
gonna call you i'm gonna email you
i might even write you a handwritten
letter okay you know
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of you again i love you sir
bye bye
i love henry winkler who doesn't love
henry winkler it was so funny uh
just at the end he's like well michael
i'm getting tired
which means enough with the interview
it's
it's our second time i mean the guy's
you know he's he's a he's a legend
and uh he's a friend and i'm just
grateful that he did it that he came
back and
talked about how he's feeling what's
going on in his world
and um just always a pleasure to have
him on
june 20th um rob danson and i are doing
a stage at two stages
uh both pacific time two o'clock p.m on
saturday june 20th and then six o'clock
the two o'clock for the
overseas uh uh fans and friends
and uh the six o'clock is for the same
for everyone uh we played a stage it a
couple weeks ago
and it just was so much fun we played
some really cool covers some originals
a couple left on laurel songs and uh i
just loved it it'll be some great prizes
and a shout out to
all my charities ronald mcdonald house
we raised a lot of money tom kristen and
i
for the omaze uh reunion thing
um a lot of money and it just made me
really happy that we did
my charity of choice the ronald mcdonald
house of los angeles but you could
donate to any ronald mcdonald house
foodonfoot.org hugely
helps the organization um become a 98
club member i'm one i'll see you down
there when we can go down there and do
the feedings again
um great folks great people who are
homeless who just want to have a new
life
and uh echoes of hope and of course arm
animal rescue mission my friend shira
you i'm sure you're seeing tweets and
retweets of mine but make sure you uh
help those animals out man she has just
she's single like me but she spends her
entire life helping animals so
also make sure you you follow if you're
listening you're liking the show
i just encourage you to email a bunch of
friends and say please subscribe and
listen and give it a chance that's all i
ask
you know the handles at insidee
insideypodcast on instagram and at
insideapod on twitter
we're on facebook uh the patreon i love
it um inside your patreon account i've
got
over 500 beautiful patrons and uh
we do so many fun things check that out
check
out a tear there's so many different
levels i mean you can
come on for i think come on for nothing
can't you just whatever just look at it
and see if you like it it's a great
community and people are becoming
friends and
i could name them off the top of my head
most of them
and then the other patron is john heater
and if you like horror movies where have
all the good horror movies gone it's
only on patreon um here's a shout out to
all the patrons
nancy d mary b leah s trisha
f sarah v yukiko jill
e brian h lauren g nico p
hi nico you just text me angelina g
lee that's what i call her cherry w
kevin r emily k bobby robert b
jason w kristin k andrew c allison l
jason d
raj sean what's up sean w
sorry about that boys joshua d emily s
cjp rocks raccoon samantha m
hamza thomas i just sent a package
jennifer m
a lot of people i sent a package to um
for those tears on patrons jennifer n
stacy b carly t vanessa in the sky rheem
jennifer s janelle b
neil w tabitha c kimberly e melissa c
we're almost done mikey
jake m marisa and
catherine hi marisa hi catherine jack s
carly smail uh judit d ramirez chris
f sarah f chad w leanne p darla w
jockey jackie jockey jockey jackie p
rodrigo s rachen ritchen you know i like
to mess your name up i love you travis b
rey a maya p megan d demario
de jennifer c moddy s
tiffany l kendrick f ashley e
kelly w you guys are awesome i i say it
every time and thank you for your
i mean look at this i mean look at this
there's a list of just top-tier patrons
i mean and every patron out there
who listens to the show or who who uh
gives zero
but but just listens to it or gives a
buck a month or whatever it is i don't
care it's just brilliant
that you support the podcast and uh keep
it going and uh
i got to do some bonus stuff today after
i'm done recording here
i'd like to read a a letter fan letter
now this is from bobby hi mr rosenbaum
mr
rosenbaum i'd like how about michael or
rosie i feel so old on
mr rosenbaum mr rosenbaum
this is bobby and i'm so grateful for
your kind words in these troubled times
i've listened to your episodes with dave
bautista and justin long and thought
they were great and look forward to
uh hearing more again thanks so much it
truly puts a smile on my face
bobby h all right this is another fan
letter from audrey my dad rarely told me
he loved me until i was an adult he
wasn't affectionate and had the worst
temper i've ever seen
in a human he often said and did things
that hurt deeply hurt deeply
and that was how he showed how he loved
me i guess
he was not the type of man who would
just go for a walk he didn't
want me to be afraid and that was how he
taught he thought he could help me
he expressed his love in ways that i
couldn't understand until i was older
i also know now that he suffered a lot
of pain inside for a long time
enough though i try to let go of all the
pain and abuse i went through as a kid
i know that i could hold on to that love
that's what i can choose to keep from my
father
i don't know that i would have been able
to come to that conclusion had i not
listened to your podcast
so thank you to you and your whole team
thank you so much
please keep doing what you're doing
i'm going to say that again please keep
doing what you're doing
audrey you got me i feel something right
in here and it makes me feel i don't
know
makes me feel like maybe sometimes i'm
doing something right
uh i'm glad i helped you
i'm glad just me being honest maybe
helped you
and uh
i always love it when you know whether i
say something or a guest usually it's
the guest
say something and it someone out there
it connects with whether it's mary
or raj or
audrey or leah or
leanne or little lisa or i mean i can go
on
but it makes me feel damn good and it
makes me feel good to be a human being
and it makes me uh want to keep doing
this so thank you so much thanks to my
guest henry winkler
and uh thank you guys thank you for
allowing me to be inside each and every
one of you
and um yo we got new merch on the uh
inside of you inside of you online we
got sweatshirts they're going fast uh
black shirts with uh my face on it and
uh
a gray shirt that just says inside of
you and um
so it's cool and uh i'm shipping them
all out myself right now
so uh i love you all
thank you for uh supporting me
supporting this show
[Music]